a very short avant
singer I'm president of
foundation strange title but the
National Museums national music
libraries and national archives in
Berlin including huge archaeological air
collections on the museum island by
chance I molds archaeologists by myself
then Jonathan tap i just presented you
heard him tenders Korean Wagner cultural
heritage preservation officer from the
Smithsonian Institution well report
reputed institution training US military
and very experienced in cultural
emergency projects I think I'm sure they
had a lot of interesting things to say
then stefano de Caro director channel of
I chrome classical archaeologist before
that general director of the antiquities
service of Italian be careful with him
is a very successful negotiator in
returning illicit things which arrived
abroad and last not least andreas
gurgaon director-general of culture and
the German Foreign Office in different
positions he hold before this one he is
very experienced those was different
kind of of culture and I think he it's
very good that he is also here with us I
mean we have not much time but i think
what what we want to do is a little bit
also to learn some lessons and perhaps
for the discussion we have to go on it's
just a few points introductory point but
around this the discussion of course are
on other points discussion can turn I
wrote down a few points which I think
are important than that I mean most
important is really and this is nothing
to do with distractions illegal traffic
of Antiquities is the objector
presentation and research together I
think first of all there should be an
agreement between all of us we have this
collections in the West for example but
we should consider is it it is in a kind
of shared heritage and we have a common
responsibility and for this reason we
also have a responsibility know what's
happening there but even if these
cultures are in crisis of the title of
these workshop is is even better
heritage in danger or her dinner at risk
but of course we also have to include
them in our working with this heritage I
mean fighting illicit traffic of
Antiquities was the most important poor
it was touched in several of the
presentations I mean the German law it
was mentioned also it's a shame we are
working hard on that to make it not
anymore so soft to make it harder with
the clear proof of provenance object ID
where does it come from has it illegally
been exported all this has to be
necessary I'm very curious how many
pieces then we remain in the antiquity
market but I'm very optimistic that we
will have latest in the coming year we
will have a reasonable law in this sense
in Germany of course this will not solve
all the questions or the problems but at
least this is what we can do and many
other European countries are on the same
way I mean we have this illicit project
it was in one lecture it was said that
we don't know the structure of this
video trafficking and so on and as
Martin here hit Marco silica and his
lecture said shortly mentioned we have
now started a project to learn about
this how is it organized how are their
networks working I think this is very
important then to work preventional II
the red lists from icon I extremely
important I mean they are helping
authorities police customs authority to
recognize pieces at border when they are
really there should be stopped for
example when we had a conference for the
same reason in December in Berlin there
was up to Karim who gave this video
message and he said it's a large problem
that Turkey I will say not very
diplomatic way is not cooperating so the
border if there are countries like Iraq
and Syria which an extreme situation the
border have to work have to function
though their needs a close cooperation
between Syria and Turkey which it seems
for the time being it's not existing
about capacity building you said that we
have similar programs now I mean when
they ask us they say send us please
acid-free packing material for tape work
uniform tablets for example seems
ridiculous but for the moment it's very
important for them training people for
special issues I think they really
should perhaps act more in an
international way coordinated way now be
are doing this within Germany but I
think we should it do it in a
national way NT awareness-raising oh
they always thought during these
lectures is really education education
education education the people in our
countries when you are as a tourist you
should not acquire such a piece even a
local man is offering to you and we
should really make people aware
collectors what they are really what the
hell they are doing when they are buying
these objects and if they are not legal
and of course it's also in these
countries they start with the
schoolbooks people must know we have
examples in Iraq for example that tribes
who are controlling areas are taking
care for the monuments this has to go on
this is extremely important and it needs
a political agenda we cannot say more of
this but this plundering instruction
have reasons we have to care also to
deal with the reasonings reasoning is
Islamism but it's also a question of how
what you see the living condition of the
people why do they get radical and all
these questions etc etc and there are
interesting NGOs heritage for peace for
example can't we support some better
country hug them better in doing their
work which we are not allowed to do
which we are afraid to do and many other
things which would be discussed in the
beginning there was this blue helmet
idea for culture yet but how how can can
they help I think four is country or
dominated regions it's already too late
etc etc I mean there's a lot to discuss
I think we should really get to some
points to go forward I mean perhaps I
want to ask you first current to what is
to experience I mean your best most
experienced of us in these cultural
emergency projects well I have to say my
experience was limited until 2003 and as
part of the US military force as a
reservist I ended up going to Baghdad
and as a curator and trying to help in
any way I could to stabilize that
collection and help the staff and there
are several people in the room that I
worked with closely there from the
British Museum and other places but I
was very surprised to learn at that
that there wasn't really a task force of
people who come parachuting in to help
in an emergency response i'm not talking
about capacity building or long-range
recovery projects I'm talking about my
objects are broken on the floor now who
is going to come and help me with that
and unfortunately we just didn't have a
lot of capacity and then much later I
was working in this area of disaster
recovery when the haiti earthquake
happened and i learned that the
smithsonian actually had a lot of
capacity to try and and deal with that
so i think one of the messages that that
I'd like to say and that we've learned
in working with partners like excuse me
like I calm and II Crom and I Kamose is
this idea that in the cultural heritage
Community my colleague Helen who spoke
about Bosnia said we have to mainstream
are thinking to make cultural heritage
part of the humanitarian response we
also have to mainstream our thinking and
stop constantly reacting and responding
we have to start thinking about
resiliency we the cultural or the
emergency planning world has far gone
beyond us by 50 years they're saying
response doesn't work reacting doesn't
work you have to have a plan in your
head before the disaster happens you
have to have money before the disaster
happens and we have to start thinking in
that way more and more Stefano what are
you thinking when you watch it all these
presentations as I chrome president I
was very it's like if I worked around my
life because I came from a country in
which there was illegal excavation in
the legal expert ation and I had to
fight with the Mafia local mafia doing
illegal excavations I think it's worse
than is isn't it oh hmm sometimes they
behave the heads in same way but and I
think that we are improved true
involving the community because also the
Mafia as a bag
grounding community and when we started
the 40 years ago there was just one
museum in Naples that was the museum of
the king the people of the countryside
in caserta province they considered
heritage something just for tourists for
buyers but not for them and when we
started the excavations fighting illegal
excavators on the world's they were
there were just scratched a bus down
with the superintendence and they fired
on Jean Paul Morel was the french
archaeologist that we called for making
rescue excavations 20 years after we are
doomed we have done a museum just where
Jean Paul Morel was targeted and a lot
after a long process of involving
schoolchildren and now it's rough it's
run by the community by the major they
pay for this museum it's a long long
process you have to to convince the
community that this is not something for
the main cities for rich people but this
is something out there and it has not to
be just archaeology because archaeology
needs a kind of education which is not
for all the people of course you can
have elements in the in the primary
school but for the most of the people
heritage is the square of their village
is the tree where I am very much
appreciated the presentation of a rose
Ian gal right because there was the idea
that has so just a watch or just a
picture of the family is heritage and
for the people to be repatriated we open
some years the echo Museum
community museum this kind of museum of
normal things for normal people is the
best innovation in the field of the
museum that the Western world there is
developed because this makes the idea
with the presentation of the player the
interpretation of the narrative expands
the field from just the top of the
heritage the beautiful Greek vases the
richest are silver to the idea that era
tidge is for everybody that everyone was
rich or poor has a narrative it's our
task to to share this idea beyond the
borders of ethnicity of race beliefs etc
in order that they are touched but not
so much to what the politicians say you
are Muslim or you are no era tidge is
the heritage in their territory they are
in this theater it's like the trees it's
like the mountains every 10 of us is
responsible for the maintenance of the
environment and the environment is both
natural and cultural we don't ask to the
trees if they are Muslim of the rocks if
they are Christians or other things they
are beautiful they're in your territory
you are a customer to lived with that
and so you have to protect this is the
next step of our Museo Roderick I think
we all can agree to that Andrea's of
course we need also somehow a political
agenda how to deal with this problem I
mean when the baby fell into the water
like in awe serac and great part of
Syria it's difficult to act you can only
act from outside and we talked about
things which can be done but when there
are approaching crisis's somewhere in
the world as representative of the
German Foreign Office if you any idea
what really we heard about this in the
morning they have not been with us this
idea from the Italian deputy
instead of culture blue helmets or
whatever or other other political parts
of a political agenda I think we we have
to think about that too yeah absolutely
it's not only a national question now
what's on stake for for foreign policy
is firstly perhaps that the the question
of identity of an international level is
a question of foreign policy and as long
as culture is part of our culture of
diplomacy but we have to we have to
shift our we have to shift our
instruments and our programs towards
towards these new challenges that and
then that perhaps part of a a first part
of not so really to shift money to
public funding for what you call a task
force over the German archaeological
Institute stressed stressed today what
they are doing in Tunisia or in the
northern Arab countries that's part of
cultural policies abroad in order to
protect in order to protect cultural
identity and second is and second is
that we are also part of that we have
our shared responsibility and that's a
question related to the work of the
museums in Europe how do you grant
access how do you educate the people in
the countries where you where you your
exponent exponents are coming from how
do you how do you connect with your with
your mozilla logic with your work with
their questions they have actually in
egypt or in northern Africa or in our
and 0 so we have that responsibility to
have a safe harbor that's great but we
also have to grant access for those
people for those people who are
connected to those to those items of
identity and thirdly and thirdly there's
still a legal framework you discussed
about the legal framework in germany and
we are both happy that the minister of
culture is taking care of that we have
to learn a lot from our it
in France when I when I think about your
task force your cabin your task force
but that's something really that's a
role model for Europe and we have to
learn something from you second on a
European level we have that European
directive for Syria and foyer arc but we
have to do more in order to protect
better and then there is an
international level so even if we all
consider that blue helmets might not be
might not be the right answer in the
right moment or on a practical level
would not work we have to raise the
awareness of the international community
that those attacks are criminals of all
crimes and that we have a responsibility
to deal with that and to look for the
prosecutors and to make that normativity
work and that's on international
abilities yes it would be create or to
have one of these cultural distractor or
how to call them for the front of the
courts in Hague I mean we heard about
what the museum's are doing the
different institutions and it's indeed I
want to repeat that it'll is a model
because your cabin area unit has about
300 members in Germany to federal police
department which is dealing with that as
only three there may be two more I like
the relations are clear but it was not
just Carabinieri see it was a combined
system because it was the carabineer it
was the legal prosecutor it was the
superintendence is that the provided
expertise it was that the tribunal it
was a joint programs unfortunately it is
Justin forcedly not by a low because the
Carabinieri are depending on the law but
it was also a happy political moment now
I think that only the Carabinieri are
working but a lot of negotiation should
be repeated by instance one of the tool
was the long term loans to the museums
in United States or elsewhere and they
are not working and it would be
important because one of the offerings
in change of the borders customs and
major impact was offering material for
study for research for publications free
of charge possibility of excavating in
Italy Italy as we have been the director
general it was cycling hundreds of
authorization for excavating not so much
because we need more materials but
because the university from abroad they
need to have more research but a
research not linked with the existing
materials in the storerooms it's a
little bit foolish who we are plenty of
materials that can be used for research
abroad we have extended the terms of the
lost for 10 years 20 years changing the
materials after and you lose the effect
of the berliner air clarinet so there is
a process but it needs to be continued
on international level with the and
Europe is a good platform for doing it
this leads me to a quest to a point that
this is the role of the museum's of
course museums perhaps there may be one
but I mean normally they'd only of a
deity public museums do not acquire
anymore it should not but I think most
do not acquire things archaeological
objects which are in doubt from the
concerning the provenance and we have
this cooperation with you in Berlin
we're really very important pieces for
three months for four months and they go
back I think this exchange is very
important for the museum's not
necessarily to acquire things and to
push the illegal antiquity market but
anyway the museums are not really they
aren't they do not play an important
role is our private people there was
recently Webster weeks ago or three
there was a documentary in the German TV
in a Spectre and filming around what's
happening in the syrian-turkish poor
and there are people from all over the
world ordering I want a mosaic is human
designs I want a statue as complete as
possible and things like that and then
they take the orders and they go on
excavating and inside there are people
producing fix fakes as well I love so
much I mean that in this case and
certain condoms is easier to excavate
illegally than to produce a fake I mean
what we heard also from you it's clear
that all the museum's institutions are
doing similar work but so training
programs and so on sending help
digitizing heritage documentation what
they're using Charles and what could we
do better together what should be more
coordinated and how I think it would
make sense i mean some of these training
programs were coordinated so that not
duplicating efforts and that requires
international cooperation in other words
sharing those resources whether they're
teaching resources or field resources
whatever they are I think that would be
a very sensible thing to do I could just
add that I think I didn't mention i'm
also the chair of the icon disaster
relief task force and one of the things
that I come starts to do is when museums
are involved in offering some sort of
training response that they're able to
kind of hear from all the different
actors and know who's doing what and are
a little bit able to help coordinate our
efforts so for instance we wanted to sue
Sounion wanted to go to Egypt and see if
there was anything we could offer for
the museum of islamic art and i come
said oh well we heard our friends from
the german archaeological Institute are
also interested in it the metropolitan
museum of art is very interested so we
were able to coordinate that effort
arrive at the same time because i know
one of our problems that the iraq museum
was you know constant loads of people
coming through to do yet another
assessment without ever actually
offering on the ground assistance and i
think that's that's just totally
critical excuse me critical dry throat
and
at and that's why we're just basically
at smithsonian focus at the moment on
small high impact projects like working
with syrian colleagues who are working
in areas that the Syrian government does
not control and they're struggling to
save their cultural heritage and we're
giving them basic emergency training
buying them equipment and sending them
back to do this work and we're working
with the academic community also
University of Pennsylvania is one of our
colleagues so so thank you so much so
you know by by working with partners
creating new networks finding the people
who can grant you that access like you
know Syrian colleagues who may be
outside of Syria now Iraqi colleagues
who can help with access on the ground
we're working with the Erbil Institute
in Iraq so you know there are a number
of ways that I think we can better
coordinate our efforts one question to
you Korean do you think that it was a
change in awareness and consciousness
you've worked a lot with the US military
for example if troops from the west into
our country realize military actions if
are some of they have to construct a
helicopter landing place not to do it in
the center of Babylon to another place
has all these terrific happenings around
the Near East and around the world if
they led to a certain change in
consciousness in concerning our military
specialists or not I think that yes it
absolutely has raised awareness but I'll
also say that as cultural heritage
professionals and as museums we have a
responsibility to train them to
recognize and understand cultural
heritage when they see it many countries
120 some countries are states parties to
the 1954 head convention which requires
you to train your military in the so
that they understand what the treaty
obligations are under 54 Hague and so I
challenge other museums to seek out
their military professionals in their
country because often they're willing
perfectly willing to do this kind of
work
can understand better about cultural
heritage and specifically I you know I
all agree 54 Hague is not going to stop
transnational terrorist groups from
doing this kind of intentional
destruction and looting they're also not
paying attention to other international
conventions like the geneva conventions
etc however our military forces are
bound by it and so they're basically
fighting with one hand tied behind their
back there fighting these guys who don't
care while being expected to protect
cultural heritage in the fight and
that's a place where we can help them
perhaps this would also be a point for
the future that in our country is that
we also has somehow we have the duty to
to train these people to educate the
military forces when they go there what
do they find I remember when I was still
president of the German archaeological
Institute and German troops went to
Afghanistan we had a program which was
not very long-lasting but a program to
train to educate at least tell them what
they will find there which cultures and
so on and what if they have to care for
and these will be your blue helmets
later a kind of pious it's very
different situation though I mean when
you can in Britain it's similar no no
we've done very simple things my
colleagues Indian citizens worked very
closely with the with the military in
training people in Afghanistan from the
example I think it's fair to say they
were very receptive to that sort of
training program but I just to come back
to what you're saying although the blue
helmets and whatever I think you know
you're dealing with a situation where
you know these people no matter how much
they respect their local heritage and
you have worked in Jordan and Syria
where people be desperately keen to
protect their cultural heritage but when
these people didn't ask to be invaded
and you know if you're confronted with
armed men with machine gun or people are
going to cut your head off what he can
do that that's the problem that we're up
against not people that want to protect
their cultural heritage many many people
do I agree with you that education is
important but these are unusual and very
extreme circumstances so before we open
the discussion one last question to
Andrea's I mean
could the Security Council of the United
Nations do something even it's just a
very symbolic thing or is this idea
rubbish I mean have we to go on on what
we are talking about or can it help if
there is a certain because this officers
can have a positive and also negative
effect yeah but you know international
conventions are perhaps not only made
for the pepper traders but also for
those who respect the rules and so in
any way in any way it could be very
important that the international
community reaffirms what she is taking
for illegal or what she wants to be a
legal framework and by reaffirming that
and thats related to the haka mention
thats related to all the unesco
conventions you can introduce some to
one or three or two new ideas so I think
I think we should go for that way and if
that conference concludes or on a paling
out that the international community has
to take care for that issue I think that
would be very supportive for what we are
doing with our without our diplomacy
anyway I think it would be good I mean
we had this conference in Berlin in
December last year in the Foreign Office
with support of the German Foreign
Office but they closed the shoulders as
we say we built an agreement between the
German institutions for legislation and
so on but here we are in a much more
international circle that's really big
people now in a few minutes here what
the the organizers will think perhaps
the outlines of this day we should put
into a paper and which we all stand
behind that and pass this forward to
UNESCO I don't know it's something I
mean we we are representing a lot of
very important institutions and our
voice our voices together is something I
think and I think this would perhaps be
a good idea about this the organizers
will later tell us but now I want to
open I mean in five minutes we have to
leave the panel but anyway I think it's
not any more time for discussion but
perhaps you have comments you have ideas
we have things which have not been
mentioned sufficiently
please and then second first and second
question and third and fourth okay and
Colin of course with Colin we will
finalize good afternoon panel I found
this very interesting day I was really
sort of a commenter with Stefano I think
congratulations the Carabinieri I've
done a research on this and the
Carabinieri assume the best police in
the world in defending cultural aspects
because of course Italy has a huge
mountain of greatest cultural artifacts
and our sites of winning which are
visited could possibly to the future to
avoid future crises like this getting
out of hand is that the Carabinieri
could set up a consultancy so many
governments around the world they could
say this is how we've done it it works
you try it and they could and these
other competition in the Middle East
they could take up the tab and then if
this happens again they're ready to go
with their own police force with the
carabineers advice to go in and stop
people are Isis and the future all
similar people like Isis in the future
it's obviously too late for Nimrod but
just the thought you want to know which
could be the role of the car of a car
placard Carabinieri you say the main
point of forsyth Carabinieri was not to
care only about the Italian antiquity
but to have a database of everything was
happening in the world and to look after
all items independently of the Italian
interest in this and to develop the
training for their forces and for other
forces or all around the world so in a
way they are they specialize themselves
in Italy they are operating on the base
of the presence of a castle nor
Carabinieri in every village so they
have a very sensitive point of view of
information wherever but in same time
they are also aware of the international
interest of this and I repeat there is
the support of very good international
law x
providing expertise when is the case for
prosecution in tribunal or when is the
case of diplomacy and they use all the
pond oprea of tools but I think that
this is a kind of experience that camp
that can be easily the core of a multi
police Interpol and if there is
something like this I think that a UN
police in a way or a un AG convention
can be based on the experience of the
Carabinieri battles over other countries
later there are a good experience also
no other countries so next turn is yours
your three may you may ask you to be
short because we are running really out
of time and actually ask you three
questions then who wants an answer can
answer and Colin rain through the last
word okay it seems to me the panel has
said many wise things but has not really
addressed what I thought we were here
for we've just seen the destruction of a
really major archaeological site it is
it is it is as though herculaneum had
been blown up now what are we going to
do to stop Isis carrying on with this
campaign and what are we going to do to
discourage other militant Islamic groups
from carrying out similar barbarities in
the future it is quite clear there's an
elephant in the room here which we're
not addressing and that is where is ice
is being supported and the truth of the
matter is it's being supported from the
Gulf and we need to put political
pressure on the Gulf to stop this going
on and I believe that that could work
nothing else can we clearly carpet
troops there but we can put political
pressure on those governments which
support this Sunni appalling Sunni
destruction sunni-led destruction was it
you were mentioned that before the day I
think it someone mentioned it I think
this would be part of a political agenda
then good afternoon my name is Mark
classic I'm a professor at Georgetown
University where I teach law in human
right
before this I worked as the head of
operations of the stolen asset recovery
initiative at the World Bank which is
joining ever between the World Bank and
the you know office of drugs and crime
but it started my career at the UN war
crimes tribunal as a prosecutor working
on the Milice which case the sharp mr.
genocide case my modest suggestion is
the fact that I think these discussions
are wonderful but I think it's worth
elevating the discussion to kind of a
supernatural level bringing together
kind of heads of state heads of industry
and all the middlemen involved in the
trade the weather being the tyrrans
companies the freeport's the transport
companies and others to see if we could
put together some sort of public-private
partnership and agreement it towards the
best standards in terms of the sale of
Antiquities from conflict zones to try
to reduce the value of the marketplace
and they're reducing the chairs finance
going to groups like Isis and others
thank you thank you then you first of
all want to say that I'm Stefano's
comments about the future of museo de ji
and the sort of direction should take I
think it's really really positive and if
you compare the conservation of the
natural world and the conservation of
the cultural world there's a lot of
comparisons in the sense that
historically you have things like zoos
being created where cultures are encased
similar to museums and the future is I
think to preserve culture in a living
environment which is really really
important because that's the only
sustainable way other comment wanted to
say was something I thought of from
james's talk in comparison to what
stefana were saying now James separated
really really clearly between this idea
of black-and-white markets whereas the
black is the issue and the white market
is something which is good I actually
think that there's a massive massive
gray area and if the grey market which
is the issue because I personally I'm a
book conserve about training and I run a
small organization to conserve books and
see examples and the issue we have is of
them manager it's being sold in small
auction houses and where no provenance
is given no background is given on this
auction houses provide a umbrella
or people to trade in radar am in a very
dubious or way because it allows someone
to remain anonymous other thing james
also spoke quite forcefully about the
role played by collectors and our
collectors should be supported if there
are legitimate i well actually argue
that the idea of collection of culture
of culture itself is one of the roots of
the issues because collectors have
indirectly destroyed history by
collecting cultural heritage which
should have been valued by a community
or humanity as a whole and it's been
turned into an object of private
enjoyment and stripped of his wife one
more sentence and it's the equivalent of
taking akka while Tiger a wild animal
and saying that you're saving different
poachers are putting it in a zoo that's
not sustainable and I think the idea of
wildlife conservation like if we apply
those lessons to heritage we've got a
lot to learn but that's all of it to say
thank you very much I'm think that the
gray market you talked about is a rather
dark gray so the last word then Colin
Renfrew and then I think that quota see
we have to give a chance to the
organizers to say something and at
five-thirty we have to leave thank you
very much ice is will come in and I
don't know my concern is with the
continued diluting which is a problem
that I think doesn't easily go away and
I certainly congratulate the new German
legal initiatives just as I congratulate
the Italian successes in getting looted
antiquities back from the Metropolitan
Museum the Getty Museum and others I
think we should name them though they
have reformed somewhat but I have one
comment and then one question and the
comment is I believe that as long as
museums continue to collect looted
antiquities post 1970 if we can use that
a guiding line as long as they collect
them by bequests not just by purchase a
long as they are willing to admit them
international museums then the problem
will continue and my question or comment
is why do you think
prices in antiquity sales in New York
for instance Christie's Sotheby's yr
auction price is still increasing I
could give you examples but I won't
because I want to conclude my question
but isn't that a pessimistic observation
that the actual prices at auction for
looted antiquities say unproven instant
equities so did Christie's and Sotheby's
for instance cycladic sculptures the
actual prices of Antiquities continue to
increase and until we find a strategy
where they start decreasing I think
we're not getting very far thank you
very correct point and the observation
is right and there's an enormous and
they're set they are not a growing
crisis there's a growing market there's
a growing necessity a growing demand and
this is the basic problem not from the
public museums but especially from very
wealthy people all over the world and
this is the basic problem I was some
time ago it was in Latin America I had
the chance to see a collection I was
shocked I was shocked what I saw I was
really shocked and when I heard about
the prices you can't imagine and when
you hear this then you believe all these
stories terrifying stories that the
third funding in importance the third
one for IES and heuristic groups by the
money they get through antiquity traffic
it is really an enormous market so but
then thank you to everybody and I think
the organizers should now have the
opportunity to say a few words to you
you